so first I don't want the rational
candidate I want the candidate that
understands the irrationality of people
again if you talk about health care or
anything I think you have to take
people's abilities and inabilities into
consideration and Obama looks to me like
he's the guy who understands people's
limitation to in the best way right now
and he's also been using principles from
behavior economics more than anybody
else so he had one early approaching his
campaign when he used the lottery the
lotteries are interesting because you
know the expected value is tiny and
people nevertheless flock to it an Obama
at an early point headed dinner but
instead of having a lot of people to
dinner it was a lottery to have dinner
with him alone and I think he raised I
think was like 8 million dollars and 41
for one event which was very successful
so I think he understands this a better
so if I hope that they will ever be a
behavioral economist on the Economic
Council I think he's probably the best
kind of date we were willing to do that
there's something that worries me about
Obama and that's the fact that we
actually don't know much about and
interestingly enough some of our
research show that when you don't know
something about somebody you fill the
gaps in an optimistic way so if you
think about all the excitement around
Obama it looked like he's you know out
of JFK like the most amazing person that
has a potential to be a president like
you would have a distribution of
abilities he would be like out there how
can it be that people expect so much I
mean we had a lot of President all good
people in the past but the expectations
are so high and I think that part of the
expectation being so high is because we
know so little the best way by the way
to think about it is dating if somebody
tells you on an online dating site they
love music people automatically assume
that the same music that they do only
later they meet them and they discovered
is not the case and they get
disappointed i think that's that's one
of the thing that worries me about obama
is that expectations are so incredibly
high and they're so incredibly high
because they're based on so little
information